[Musique]
stéphane pourtant juste la semaine
d'avant
stéphane je m'appelle eric ruf je suis
administrateur général de la comédie
française après y avoir été sociétaire
pendant de longues années et
pensionnaires avant donc ça fait 23 24
bientôt 25 ans je crois il ça frise le
quart de siècle
on reprend juste ça françois acteurs
avant tout mais je suis aussi
scénographe et je suis aussi metteur en
scène est donc maintenant
administrateurs de cette maison je
consacre toutes mes soirées ou bien
avoir ici toutes les premières
évidemment où j'ai aussi les choses
protocolaire à faire aider général de
presse où je me dois d'être là et ce
terrain je me dois de soutenir aussi
quand il ya des problèmes voilà d'être
l'un puis le reste du temps je vais dans
d'autres théâtres à paris en bus en
banlieue et en province aussi j'essaye
de le faire voir à l'étranger
[Musique]
je suis censé aussi pouvoir repérer
quels seront les classiques de demain
nous devons redonner dans une acception
contemporaine tous les classiques que
chaque génération devrait voir
et puis de temps en temps voilà on fait
rentrer aussi des formes plus
particulière la règle du jeu
le film de renoir donc le scénario et le
scénario des damnés de visconti de ses
acolytes thérèse si jamais on te disait
tiens c'est trop marécageux c'est trop
humide il faudrait revenir une chose
plus sage comment tu fais tu pulvérise
donc en gros je suis un peu responsable
de tout mais notamment de l'organisation
qui s'appelle un peu un casse tête
chinois quand même on fait à peu près
800 lever de rideau par an chez 61,65
acteurs pour faire tout ça et ça n'est
pas simple sur les administrateurs passe
et la troupe reste voilà
[Musique]
ça désespère les gens mais y'a pas
d'audition pour rentrer avec mehdi
française je les engage parce que c'est
de bons acteurs je les engage
généralement parce que j'ai tout d'un
coup un rôle que je n'arrive pas pour
voir cette manière de dire no no no no
no mais je préfère on joue 200 300 fois
par an quand on est comédien dans cette
dans cette maison c'est rare de faire ça
à l'extérieur on arrive pas innocemment
dans cette maison on se dit pas je viens
cachetonner où je vais venir pour un an
il ya quelque chose immédiatement con
con qu'on ressent pas de l'ordre des
fantômes
ça n'est pas ça responsabilise
ça c'est normal
la répétition qui m'appelle qui commet 0
mais le gibier
[Musique]